Hello!
Okay, I'm gonna head over to the place.
The place, to the place.
To the place.
Okay, off we go.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Woohoo!
Hi, we've got this weird shape again that we have no idea.
What is that?
What it is?
Yeah.
It's like a Primo gem.
Oh wait, it's...
It's the Triforce of Pragante.
try and force the freak out
which is perfect but i don't know if you guys can see the
example make a heart instead like oh like a like a like a
that like a that maybe oh it's just work if someone like i
think you have to like yeah so like oh oh oh huh okay you
also do another seat yeah another need one hand oh i see oh
cute it's a heart yeah oh it's so sweet oh so cute bunny
chicky yeah should we do like an intro of oh yeah what we've
decided oh i mean should we say what we're doing i know
right can you guys can you guess what we're doing yeah oh
wait it's like isabel oh yeah
oh that's the fun part that sounds nice wait that sounds
really good eating paper no it specifically says on the back
do not eat do not eat it no do not do not do it don't do it
oh it really says which is confusing because the logo is
like a cat cooking yeah a cat cooking yeah i'm not sure what
that's about well it's because we're about to cook we're
gonna work we're cooking up something really good yeah it
does it does it's for people like us that has the warning
that you can't eat it because i was looking last night vicky
was doing a test a test one oh yes i was like i was like i
want to eat this guys we're making custom labum i was like
shopping for charms and I was like, I saw the Labubus and I
was like, yep, yep, put them in my basket.
We're definitely going to want those on our checkies, yes.
Oh my gosh, yeah, it's so exciting.
You guys, so I got like colors for ourselves.
I got like a light blue, light pink, light green, which is
so cute.
I found it cute how like the light, is this the light pink
yet?
The light pink is called baby.
Baby.
Oh, we were talking last night, right?
So the blue was called Mermaid.
Yeah, the blue, I think is M, no, that's not the blue.
What's the blue?
Mermaid.
And then confusingly, the mint green is fairy, which is cute
as well.
I don't know.
So you've got a mermaid.
So this isn't just a mythic, well, they're not all mythical
creatures, but like you got a mermaid, you got a fairy, and
a baby.
And a baby.
But you know, babies are not real.
It's so cute.
What's yellow?
Is it egg?
Pine.
Pineapple.
Apple.
Yeah, I feel like a lot of them are like food.
Milk.
Tropical.
This one's sugar.
Sugar.
Oh, now I'm gonna eat it.
Oh, I'm gonna eat it.
I feel like the black one was called Night.
Night.
From my channel, the Hedgehog Chicken.
That's the rating chicken.
Yay!
Or at least the cheque holder, top loaders.
Oh, we shall introduce our ones who wants to go first.
Yeah, go for it.
Phoebe.
Go for it, Phoebe.
Okay, so each of us are going to be decorating our chequies
from the chequie, the patreon.
Yay!
The chequie club.
Each of us chose one.
On top of that, I've got my daughter.
Aww, that was such a cutie!
It was between one that was like very baby looking and then
this edged lord emo looking picture.
I love it.
And then they had the idea of, well I could decorate it very
edgy so I'm gonna have an edgy one.
Yeah, yeah.
Me and Fujikaze.
Oh my god.
Originally I had photoshopped my IRL self next to him but it
was too real looking so.
Precious lace lavi, lavi doodle the Phoebe there.
So that I will not be too parasocial.
And then...
Be more parasocial.
Yeah, be more parasocial.
You heard it here.
I'm allowed to be more parasocial.
And then my Kamioshi Ranka from Macross for the time.
So excited.
What do you guys have?
Okay, so we've got...
I'm going for the snow festival one from the fan club so
nice uh give me a second BRB I guess
we're back sorry sorry it was my shoes that I ordered sorry
sorry anyway what were we doing yes buy checkies of course
we've got my my precious boy Shadow the Hedgehog and we've
got was the name John John the Moose that's very exciting
but what's his name you guys we were like oh you got chat
will remember yeah the Moose from RV's area yeah I think I
think it was John who is John the Moose John the wait who is
wait is that not John the Moose yeah is that not is that not
what he's called wait no I feel like it wasn't John.
It was Johnny, Johnny.
Johnny.
Yeah, Johnny.
Okay, close, close.
Yeah, sorry about the lens, guys.
We tried wiping it, it's not doing anything, so it's what it
is.
I got ectoplasm all over it, sorry.
It's part of the immersion.
Yeah.
It's really hard to get off.
Yeah, no idea what's up with that, but yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Exciting.
And then what about, what about?
I have myself as well.
precious acrobatana and then i have of course drawn us a lot
oh beautiful beautiful nice picture you chose yeah scruncle
man and then yeah this one um snake on the torture i i was i
sent this image to mickey and i was like please crop it so
it's just snake on the torture
Definitely got to get some Laboobus on there.
Oh, yeah.
You want the glass?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Well, I guess...
I do have a backup just in case.
Yeah, we're gonna try for three each, but we have backups
too.
I'm scared.
Vicky's got a backup shadow.
I do.
Yeah.
And then...
I mean, I can print anything else you guys want.
Oh, backup.
put skin in a suit that is a nice photo as well yeah heck
yeah the lens smudge is a very golden age of cinema oh
thanks guys this is the golden age of cinema decorating
decorating snake in the torture device exciting oh my gosh
which one are we gonna start with i kind of i'm i think i
might start with the you know because i think it's gonna get
more and more cursed as it goes along Oh no, but maybe I
should do one of the curse ones.
What are you guys?
I think I'm like, because I had never done this before and
I'm like, what if I want the one that I'm like, you might
mess up on, right?
Exactly, that I'm going to mess up on as, but I'm like, this
one's going to be my magnum opus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Save him.
I'm going to do John the Moose first, personally.
I'll do Ocelot first.
Oh boy, um, I'll do...
I'll do Cuzzy first.
Yeah.
Oh.
right well guys just get stuck in so basically you take the
lid off the thing oh that one's already oh yeah because i
used that one okay so they should have a little i think
they'll have a little thing on the end that you've got to
take off oh for anyone wondering this is kind of the inspo
yeah even more the check-in yeah this is the inspo yeah
it'll turn out something ideally Something like that.
Probably not as pretty.
We have not just all of these, uh, demo whips, but we also
have chaos emeralds.
Why are they so small?
Guys, there was a picture.
They look proper emeralds.
I can't get them even open.
They were proper emerald size.
And look how tiny they are.
This is ridiculous.
Oh, but they look nice, I think.
Look at this.
Oh, so small.
That's so small.
I made the effort to get the right thing.
seven colors and everything chaos small rolls yeah they're
so tiny but no they do look they do look good i i tried them
out on the test one yesterday and they look pretty nice so
yeah we've got lots of different colors we got tree frogs
tree frogs we got so pretty we have we have lots of stickers
Lots of different stickers.
Fluffy ones.
Yeah.
We've even got checky pens if you guys want to like write
anything on the, well, we've already put them in there now,
so maybe we'll have to write anything.
We have so much stuff to get ready and I'm so excited.
Okay, I'm going straight for John personally.
I'm gonna watch you do it.
Yeah.
Guys, did you see the test one?
I did it so bad.
I really don't think it's gonna help you at all, but okay.
Oh wait, is there like a paper?
to test some of the oh sure sure go go for it yeah go for it
that's a good idea yeah can i want that thing yeah okay see
how it's harder how soft it performs oh it's actually it's
so pretty it's so pretty and like oh okay you guys probably
see it wow
i want to eat it i want to eat it yeah that looks so good oh
my god that looks so nice or like it yeah it looks like
there's really really minty toothpaste yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it's so shiny it's so pretty i mean we could we could
just like do all of the colors and show everyone so that was
emerald do you need the thingy for it because yes yeah so
one of them is uh ruined the one okay guys so the one i did
yesterday uh kiwi color takes like one to three hours for
the stuff to dry so it was wet when I when I like put this
on some tissue and then obviously dried up and now I can't
get the stuff out so yeah sorry we might not be able to use
kiwi color I got it on oh no there's tissue I'll bring this
one slightly open no hopefully it's fine hopefully it's yeah
it's like squeezing out this one is the pastel green whoa
it's so pretty oh that's nice I think it's like kind of
translucent like forbidden frosting no don't eat it don't
eat it that's why it's forbidden frosting oh my gosh it's
all so pretty yeah I think as long as because we're like
decorating them all at the same time so it should be fun
yeah feel we can't use um the nozzle is like messed up so if
you use a different nozzle like maybe you use one of the
other green nozzles maybe yeah okay okay okay oh it's a nice
metallic can i try baby yeah try baby the baby oh baby is so
baby oh my oh my god i didn't do it very nice oh it looks
It's really hard to tell on the camera, but it's nice and
soft.
Wow.
Sorry.
No, no, no.
I think I have one of them.
Yeah.
I like it.
Careful.
You just dipped this one.
Oh, did I dip it?
Oh.
All right.
Let's try some.
What's this?
Pineapple.
Yummy.
Ooh.
Oh, that one's not so...
It looks like mustard.
Oh, it does look like mustard.
Yeah.
Less keen on that one.
I think the translucent ones look better actually.
Yeah Because the kiwi one also wasn't the translucent thing
and it didn't look that great.
I think the translucent ones look better.
Yeah pretty
Yeah, I tried to get like everyone's you know colors tried
to get some also greens fur for snake and yeah, so hopefully
we got a good selection as early.
Tropical.
Oh, tropical.
Oh, feel free to take it.
Yeah, change it.
Oh,
that's pretty.
Oh, that's nice.
That's my butter and the butter.
This one definitely looks the worst to eat so long.
I was gonna use yellows and oranges for Kazae, but maybe
we'll see about the yellows.
This is mermaid.
Mermaid.
Oh, wait, that's so pretty.
It's so pretty!
Oh my gosh, can I lick it actually?
It says, Technically.
I mean, anything is lickable if you just try.
I'm already dead, it's fine.
Oh, that looks kind of nice actually.
What's this?
Apple.
That's the one I already used.
That's really nice.
Oh my gosh, it looks good.
Oh, nice.
Very nice indeed.
This is looking so good.
I'm so excited.
I don't think so.
Just the kiwi, like the, yeah, we might have to use one of
the other green nozzles if you guys want to use the kiwi
color.
But to be honest, I think the greens we have are really
nice.
One of them is like translucent.
Yeah, one of them is the translucent style.
And one of them is like the mustard style.
Milk and sugar.
Oh, I'm sure this, the sugar is probably the shiny one.
I figured we'd probably use a lot of white so I've got a
couple.
All right guys, well I'm gonna get started with the emerald
on John the Moose.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh, I'm scared.
Don't want to mess it up.
Actually, can you move my face a little?
Yes.
You can move it?
Probably underneath the shadow.
Or like, you could put it like on top.
Oh, yeah, that works.
There?
Yeah, that works.
There we go.
Okay, sorry.
All right.
Yeah, maybe we can make chat a little small.
Sorry, guys.
Come on.
Like the tops of McVitie's ice gem biscuits.
Oh, yeah, the ice gems!
What's an ice gem?
Guys, they've never had ice gems!
What does that mean?
It's ice gem.
Wait, guys, there's ice gems British only.
Oh, I am it.
Ice gems.
or ice gems oh they're delicious oh they are they are
everything beautiful they're so good wait oh that's so yummy
i would just pop a bunch of them in my oh my gosh the
translucent ones come out so much better no guys i would
seriously advise against using pine or milk just because
these ones are so much better like i did the other one for
test yesterday and this is so much nicer I'm like trying, so
I saw it wears red, but obviously I want green for his
boyfriend.
Oh yeah.
How do I make it now look like Christmas?
Oh, that's true, yeah.
I really thought I was going to choose a Kasey picture that
would have him like with flowers and he's typically has
orange and stuff, but I chose the beach picture instead, so
I'm like, oh.
I didn't take my own advice.
I think flowers would still look nice because you're there,
you know?
Oh.
the more over there actually if you don't mind me oh yeah do
you want any in particular um actually i'll take the roses
okay yeah nice i'm like blotting mine out over it i didn't
take my own advice i used the mustard it looks the
comparison is ridiculous oh my god it's like drinking it's
the mustard on the burger that we turned them into
Oh my god!
No!
John!
Oh my god.
Oh, I should not have done that.
I've ruined him.
No!
It's happy accidents or something.
Oh my gosh, why is it so thick?
Guys, do not use, don't use this one.
I'm just telling you now.
It's more for like similar with this one, like the smudging,
like...
Yeah, maybe.
Less of like a plopping.
More of a sludging.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go for like a full line of it and see if that
works.
I know, maybe I love this.
I'm just thinking that snake's on his mind.
Oh my gosh, cute.
It's how you guys enjoy being in Japan.
I'm sleepy.
You are still jet lagged.
probably definitely I might have fixed my jet lag last night
maybe maybe yeah that's good though yeah last night was like
my first night properly comfortably sleeping something like
that but maybe it's because I feel so at home when I'm here
with oh we were talking before this about how I don't know
how how special the group is to us and I was saying that I
don't think anything's ever been So important to me as Dan
said to it is So I feel very you guys are home
I definitely feel the same way So nice to do stuff together
with you guys
Oh dear oh dear of course you can which color would you like
of the seven chaos emma guys they're literally accurate can
i just get some appreciation i literally picked out the
exact ones okay they're so beautiful uh which one would you
like um we'll go with the pink pink oh that'll be a nice
contrast yeah thank you yeah i'm not gonna lie this is i'm
glad i did this one first oh my god it ain't looking great
it's not it's not the vibe guys i'm not gonna lie a vibe
though it is so yeah it's a vibe it's not not quite what i
was envisioning um where are you envisioning i thought
because like you know rv there yeah it's got like the yellow
hills and the green trees so i was sort of thinking oh
that'd be nice you know and we got like a a burger who no i
I don't think we do.
I don't think so, unfortunately.
We got a can of beer.
No, we have a coffee, that'll do.
But I'll be sweet because it's not him.
It's not sweet.
It's actually spicy.
Oh my gosh, we're yours is looking so cute already.
No!
It's very delicious.
Thank you.
Yeah, we'll use Michelle.
I don't know if he was like, girl, you put your phrase,
Vicky's looks like she was decorating a cupcake.
Okay, that's why I'm trying.
I'm trying.
Oh my gosh.
It looks good.
Everybody's a hater.
Yeah, don't listen to that.
Yeah.
Live your truth.
What a hater.
Okay, I'm gonna put, I feel like Kappy Bar is a kind of
like, a bit like a moose.
Yeah, a bit like a moose.
Yeah.
There we go.
cute and then yeah so for any of you guys who want to try
our deco whip it takes one to three hours till it gets to
like a podgy texture and it takes one to three days to fully
dry so yeah takes a while till you get like the the proper
look oh yeah the tweezers I mean to be honest I think I'm I
think I'm nearly done with this guy
That is gonna take like a like two weeks to try.
It's so So much Okay guys, you want to see the completed
first everybody clap Please clap for me, please clap for me.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
It's beautiful.
Thank you so much.
I'm gonna Thank you.
You know what?
I think Johnny would love it yeah i think so too johnny
would be thrilled johnny if you're watching johnny we're
sorry for turning you into a burger and hope hope you loved
it oh my god i got the mustard stuff all over my hand oh no
i know it's like really hard not to oh my ears look so cute
oh it looks so nice yeah oh with this with the clowns it's
perfect right yeah like a springtime beach trip yeah Stand
down.
This reminds me, I've worked at a lot of bakeries for my
part-time jobs in the past and this reminds me of like
decorating cookies.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, this is like a little more liquidy than you normally.
I feel like our love is coming through.
Oh, it looks so pretty.
The blue is so lovely.
That's such a nice blue.
This is already like 5,000 times better than this.
Johnny.
Guys, consensus.
Do I put the rainbow?
I didn't even put the rainbow.
Yeah!
Do it!
Okay.
I'll chat.
Consensus.
Oh.
Oh!
No!
I have to put the rainbow.
There is no choice.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Okay, good.
I think I'm good with Ocelot, then.
This is like... I thought this would take five million years
yeah it looks so beautiful
oh yeah oh it smells bad yeah it does not smell good it does
not smell good we might need to open a window oh my god it
smells so bad I think it's like particularly the sugar one
smells really bad I think I couldn't smell it until yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what is it about that one okay I'm
kind of concerned but we'll continue is that the one that
was slightly open let's not think about it let's not think
about it I'm sure it's fine right chat I'm sure it's fine
sure oh it looks so good thank you wait you need the pink
the fuzzy ones yeah it would look so snowy yeah oh my gosh
it's looking so cute so far yeah oh i'm obsessed okay i'm
like watching you do it maybe i should be using the tweezers
i feel like at some point i'm gonna drop like 5 000 of these
gems onto this i know i was like i don't even know if i got
them in there i'm just gonna i don't actually think that
that's working it's just sticking to the Oh no, oh no!
I know it's difficult.
We're escaping.
Okay, I'm just gonna go for sprinkling them over now.
I've given up.
I like kind of dip my finger in so they can see if it
sticks.
Anyone in Chandan Dekka Whip before?
You guys got any tips for us?
I know, please.
This is the first time for all of us, so.
Someone said the lens isn't blurry.
Vicky's just moving really, really fast.
Yeah, yeah, I'm just moving like Sonic, guys.
Like Sonic.
How blurred am I?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Are you even there?
Where did your arm go?
Oh my gosh.
I feel like a kid when they're just like, wow, why are you?
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Yes, honey, you're moving very fast.
Oh, I didn't see you.
Oh, look at that.
Okay, next I'm gonna do Akihara!
Yay!
Oh my god, wait, this looks adorable with the snow fairies.
I'm obsessed.
Oh yeah!
Wait, that's so pretty!
Guys, I know you can't see right now, but I can't wait to
show you.
She leveled up so fast.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, the glow up is unreal.
Wait, I keep using the same colors.
Wait, maybe I should use...
Just don't use the mustard.
I'm just don't do it.
I'm going to move it away.
I think the red is nice.
Are we done?
So pretty.
Oh my gosh, I love it.
Wow.
Look at oranges.
When I think of them, I think of like orange and yellow, but
that yellow was...
No, don't do it.
Don't do it.
It's not worth it.
I'm going to move it away so you won't get it.
Oh, it is so very little.
Thank you, chat.
Thank you.
So good.
Actually, can I have the baby?
Wait, where is this?
I think that's baby, no?
I wish to see the baby.
That is what you're making.
Yeah, that's baby.
I guess it's the baby.
I was like, let's see.
It's so pretty.
Wait, was I using baby this whole time?
Is this baby?
Yeah, that's baby.
Oh!
I thought it was sugar for some reason.
No.
So how is sugar?
We know it was sugar because it smells terrible.
It smells so bad.
Oh, does it?
Oh, I love that it comes out.
Oh, wait, don't put it in your nose, Phoebe.
I don't know.
It just smells bad.
And I smell this one, I smell baby, it smells like red.
Oh!
Why?
It smells so bad.
Okay, baby smells...
It doesn't smell good, but it does not smell like that.
No, no, no.
Baby doesn't smell good, okay.
No, it is so cursed, guys.
It's really cursed.
Oh.
Here, do you want to use baby again?
I'm, like, wondering...
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm actually so proud of this.
Is that the deco wig?
Yeah.
It looks...
It looks like flowers, right?
It's crazy!
Yeah, I don't know how.
Whoa.
Was there a blue Labooboo?
Oh, there it is.
I love this color combo.
That's purple.
We have purple.
Do I want to ruin this, what I've already done though?
What do you mean ruin?
Oh, that looks so cute, Minto.
Hey, thank you.
Oh my god.
It's very pretty.
So cute.
Oh.
I like how we have...
We have Snow Festival, Akihabara, and Ikea.
Hey, listen, all other things.
All great places, honestly.
Oh, yes, yes.
I do think...
I mean, Ikea can be a great place for like a date.
Because can you imagine like, you go and you have like the
awesome like meatballs.
I love the meatballs.
So good.
You hit the board.
And then you go look at like the blow high the other the
plushies and stuff And then you fantasize about having a
house together and you like think about what kind of Oh, can
I can I live there too?
Oh, yeah, okay We're both the triangle together together No,
when I go to Ikea I'm always like bouncing on the beds to
get told You're allowed to do that?
No.
I think I used to like play hide-and-seek with my friends in
Ikea.
Okay, but that's hard to resist.
Wait, you would go with your friends?
I would go with my parents.
No, no, it's a great place to play hide-and-seek.
It's fantastic.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I bet.
I don't know if I want to do any more to this or if I'm just
gonna...
No, it looks really good.
Oh, guys.
It's not as simple as that.
Yeah, exactly.
You could, if you want to put these, like on the this, it
could look like snowflakes.
That'd be so cute!
Okay, yes, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
Are you guys okay with me switching the greens real quick to
see if you're- Of course, okay.
Yeah, I hope it doesn't ruin it.
Are you going for kiwi?
Cause I highly would not recommend it.
You don't, it's like the mustard one.
Shall we take a look?
Do you guys want a science?
Go for it if you want.
For science.
But I would highly not recommend it.
But you'll have to get rid of the mints in there first.
Oh, and then it becomes a...
What is happening?
Oh, I keep... Oh, I'm telling you, this is the one you use
for your test, and I thought it looked delicious.
Like, I thought it looked like a cupcake.
Like, do you ever really get the cupcakes that have, like,
fake roses on top?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, yeah, yeah.
Now you see what I mean.
Uh-oh, it's happening.
Oh, this is a mistake.
A mistaki.
Yeah, mistaki.
Actually, should I lube it up and knock you that right off?
Yes!
Laboobu it up.
Actually, just the other day, we saw a girl with the same
exact Laboobu.
Yes!
Oh my gosh, I was like Laboobu twin.
I got a, I was showing them, I got a jump of my, look guys,
listen, listen, it is cute.
Look, up until now, okay, I've heard this Laboobu a while.
A friend gave it to me and I like it a lot.
And I hadn't ever got outfit for it and I finally got it a
little sweater.
It's very cute, I will admit.
You look so old.
You look so little.
Same energy.
Ricky look.
Breakster.
I'm excited.
Oh yeah, the roses?
Yeah.
Definitely.
Alright guys, I'm not gonna do any more to it.
It might ruin it.
I'm proud of that.
Capet!
Let's just compare.
Oh my God, wait, I just got stuff over here, it's fine.
Okay.
So the sticky back, it just completely fell off.
Oh, yeah.
That's fine, I'll use this.
Okay, chat, here is my glow up.
Are you proud of me?
We're so proud.
Thank you, chat, thank you so much.
Thank you.
It's so pretty.
Thank you so much.
It's so nice.
Well, no, I keep getting the stuff everywhere.
Sorry in the van.
I smell it.
It's
so bad.
It's so bad.
I squished it once.
Okay, never mind.
I actually know I was gonna fix Ocelot a little bit.
You can fix him, I believe you.
Oh look, I can't be fixed.
There's no fixing him.
Are you gonna have the Ocelot and Snake together?
Well, this Ocelot and this Snake don't...
Oh, they're different.
timelines or something there there's this is the wrong snake
oh no oh okay I see maybe I shouldn't know the right if I
asked you to print you have the one yeah yeah I can do it
but I want to do the torture snake so I mean I could change
him out from fliskin I think we'll have time to do more to
be fair I think it's totally fine if you want to do that all
right okay I'm gonna find the picture guys all right guys
I'm gonna start shadow I'm so excited yes okay I'm gonna do
sorry again i'm gonna do the smelly one i'm gonna do like
i'm gonna do alternate colors it's gonna look so good oh
it's gonna look so nice yes the red yeah i am are you sure
you don't want to use the yellow he's got some yellow i i'm
scared of the yellow i'm so scared of the yellow no oh that
looks good already that looks nice thanks oh it can chat see
there it is yeah yeah it looks good
Oh my gosh.
Look at how this photo is like me kissing me.
Oh beautiful!
Did you get it on your head?
I got the green!
The yucky green!
Oh it's in my nails!
Oh no!
Girl don't use that yucky green.
Do you need the scissors?
Like to kind of poke into it.
Oh I thought you were like going to chop off your finger.
It's too late.
Chop them up.
Thank you.
I think I might be okay.
Okay, if I did this one, could you like print it and then
I'd use it sideways?
Yes, the answer is absolutely.
Okay, okay.
I think it would go well with it.
All right, I'll send this in the group chat.
I might have to disappear for two seconds to get more film,
but yes, I can do it.
Oh, is there none left?
No, no, I got some over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I thought you said there was one left in the thing, so
I'm like...
I used it, but I got more.
Oh, I got more.
i've got i've got more packs yeah yeah yeah absolutely no
they are to be used this is the best use chat have i done
the right order for the colors i think i have i've just done
red so back on black again keeping the sequence all right so
it's like it's a stream being recorded on a roll of film
read the pinned message read it it's science oh i it so
blurry yeah i don't know i'm sorry it's my camera okay wow
it's like so clear and then oh that's how you make the
flowers yeah yeah you gotta like snap it why is it just
we'll get close guys we'll get close do you like miffy oh
cute this is a miffy loving household yeah so cute right
it's coming it's coming along it's coming along okay i sent
the picture whenever no rush okay have you got another one
to decorate in the meantime I'll just oh yeah yeah I'm
working on it okay yeah no no worries I will print it in a
second thank you all right gotta be very careful with each
of the each of the chaos animals okay I'm
just gonna take the lids off the the jewels how'd you get
orange one got it got it got it got it got it all right
so what do you guys usually do for your oshikatsu i mean
this is one of one of the things people do but uh what's
your use taking pictures with the plushies yeah yeah lots of
newies like a checky machine yeah i got you guys i like
themed outfits oh cute oh that's cute so like when i went to
on the other day I had a covenin theme.
Oh, so nice.
That was my favorite form of Oshkatsu.
Ow.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I did.
Okay, the blue ones did.
For me, I like taking my plushie around.
I take my little plushie shadow to wherever I'm going and
take pictures.
We can't wait for you to show the pictures of your last.
Yeah, I'm so excited.
Yeah.
Because there are lots of cute little shadow pictures.
Alright, does anyone fancy the challenge of opening these?
Oh!
Oh, good.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, I got- Oh, I was like- So strong!
Yay!
Thank you.
Do you guys struggle with opening water bottles?
Yes!
Okay, okay, thank God.
Oh, I was like- I was like- I hope I'm not alone in this.
Yeah, I think it's just like, I always have to use my
sleeves and like twist it out.
And then that only like sometimes works.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I love the, oh, that's so good.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, Phoebe, that's such a good idea.
It's, oh my gosh.
This reminds me of being in elementary school.
Oh yeah, like the art projects.
Yeah, is this that kind of vibe?
Those were so cool.
Yeah.
I hope the kids do art projects still nowadays.
I hope.
Can someone hand me the stars?
Of course.
These blue and white ones?
Dozo.
Thank you.
Oh, rogue jewel.
No idea where that went.
Oh, well.
Oh.
I keep just dropping the jewels everywhere.
The Chaos Emeralds, they're like the Shikon jewel.
Yeah!
She cannot be found.
Damn, Inuyasha mentioned in the year of our Lord, 2026.
I'll always find an excuse to mention Inuyasha.
Um, did you crush on Inuyasha?
Oh yeah.
And it didn't help that he has the same voice actor as Yumi
T.
Conan?
Oh!
That's like the Tuobama!
I was like, I'm obsessed.
I did not realize that.
So there's like fan, or not fan art, there's official art of
like the Tuobama.
Is his voice, is his say you the same as Ramos as well?
Maybe?
Maybe, I have a chance.
It would be so Takashi Minigura can do that.
I know, right?
She had a way of making such husbands.
I know!
Yeah!
Although not all the time.
It's Ataru from Urse Yatsura.
Oh yeah.
She has good vibes too.
Ramu-chan, Ramu-chan, we're going.
I keep getting the top of my top loader but it's okay.
He is one more.
He is!
Oh yes!
Such husband.
Yeah.
I gotta get it off my finger.
Everybody!
Love it.
Alright.
Two down.
Can I have another tissue Phoebe?
I'm sorry.
Oh, plump.
Tissue master Phoebe.
That's what they call me.
Don't forget about the Labubu.
Actually, I don't even have one.
Labubu's out of style now.
Are they?
I don't know.
I still have people in Japan still with them.
But maybe, I feel like I haven't heard about them as much
recently.
Right.
I went to this, um, Dubai Chocolate Specialized Place back
in the States.
Oh yeah.
They just for some reason had like Labubus on their door,
like they printed on their door.
They weren't doing a Labubu collab.
They were just...
Just had them?
They just had them.
As part of their decor.
Like I was like, those are not.
No, I'm just debating what to add other than a Labubu to my
shadow.
So far.
You could add, well you can't add the happy smile.
Do you want to put the rainbow?
Yeah, I feel like the rainbow is giving the energy.
It's a cute little lollipop.
I like the lollipop as well.
He's a little sweetie.
Yeah.
He acts all edgy and cool, but really, he's giving pink
lollipops and lollipops.
Yeah.
Yeah, you could decorate with like the pink around him or
something.
Yeah, that would be cute.
The hearts, yes.
Oh my gosh, yes.
I'm gonna do those.
Cute!
Snake?
Snake!
Stop, you only be.
Ooh.
What's a dangerous?
I keep dipping my hands into various colors.
I'm just having to sort of like...
wipe it off.
these stickers like the sticky bit comes off so just keep
that in mind oh yeah they do i think they were from the 100
yen shop that's okay too big oh well done it now oh wait
wait i've got coffee shadow needs coffee on them perfect
perfect perfect perfect he loves coffee oh there were like
Oh, I'm cute!
Oh, it's really cute.
It's so cute.
Oh, I'll put a corn, just because.
Shadow...
Which one, which color do I go for?
Do I go for the emerald or like the blue?
Because Shadow Moses is so blue.
But I don't...
It's kind of like greenish in the picture.
Oh, what?
They're voting.
Should I do a poll?
Oh, that's okay.
Blue will match the sneaking color.
The blue?
i can do both i could do like a corner or something this is
pretty i don't remember what this one looks like yeah this
is the emerald one emerald's nice yeah oh that guy yeah yeah
it's cute pink i didn't that's not an option guys
you can draw on top of it it seems to work just so you know
wait what did you i've done him some little cheeks
Okay, okay, chat You must though I think I think I think I
think it's done Oh my gosh, that's so cute That's perfect.
It's actually perfect.
My Ikea trip Yes, springtime Ikea It's so pretty I put a
little friend and I didn't want to get hungry so I gave it a
corn the corn is not on brand but you know it's it can snack
on it i love it
ikea spring sale yeah ikea spring sale cool so cute thank
you yeah all right i think shadow is also ready oh my god
nice I'm so baby girl.
Oh, he's so baby girl.
He's so baby girl.
His coffee, his pink laboo, his lollipop, so beautiful.
Okay, I think he might be my most proud work.
Yeah.
Okay, let me print the other one and also get myself
something.
Some other Trekkie.
Oh.
Oh, the stinky sugar scent.
Okay, be careful.
Oh.
You could smell it immediately.
God.
I hate to wash my hands.
Tsuki's image color is white.
But Tsuki's very, very edgy in this one.
So we're gonna, now that Vicky's done with shadow, I can use
the black.
I'm like scared of touching the other one on accident.
I feel that.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Maybe.
Yeah.
We can put them somewhere else if you want.
Can you all do this?
It's so cute.
Do you want to put yours here too?
Yeah, I'm a little bit of ice in there.
Come on, baby.
Look at you guys.
Look at how scrunk we use.
Oh, the next one though, I can use a toddler egg.
Oh, I'm excited.
Snake on the portrait device.
That's what you have to do.
Unless you die.
Maybe you're gonna feel left out if you don't have a mean
one princess.
Any suggestions for things to do?
I was trying to think.
Yours are also cute though.
Yeah.
Let me think about what I could do for him.
No.
I probably don't.
Ignore the printing noises in the background.
I don't think you can hear it.
I'm gonna borrow your flowers.
I have a picture of my friend's cat.
I'm doing the most horrible pose.
Or maybe.
But I would need to see.
Let's see.
Oh, everybody's spamming the six of an emote now.
Thanks.
Thanks for the solidarity.
I don't know if this can be cropped properly, but it's this.
Mickey, should I put it on the picture?
Put it in the...
I don't know how you're going to crop it.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I'm working out how to do mintos, the small one.
Oh no, is it not?
Don't worry.
I'll be able to edit it or something.
If it's cut off, that's okay too.
It could just say dumb bitch.
At the moment, it doesn't even have snake in it.
It just says, I may be dumb bitch.
Guys, don't question me.
them when I'm printing okay don't question don't worry about
it don't worry about it I feel like I need to try and edit
them I mean I'll try and print you what it does do okay oh
no I don't want you to waste your phone it's quite funny
though if it works that's good too also like they can always
You can always change out images later.
It's nice about a top loader.
Why is she so pretty?
I'm stealing the materials.
Actually, I'll do the light one.
Ooh, these are so nice.
Oh my god, the contrast is with your previous ones.
It's crazy.
Whoa.
I'm trying to think of ways to make it more edgy.
It's not a phase you guys, it's not a phase.
It's not.
Suki's always like, it's not a phase mom and then runs up
into her little bunny tower and I'm like, kids.
Kids.
She'll learn when she's older.
And then we're gonna have a dramatic bonding moment.
I know you were, I know you were, I know you You were a
strict parent to me for a good reason.
No, I was too hard on you.
And then we're going to run and hug each other.
Yeah, I see you.
Yeah.
Or like, people in chat, or you guys too.
One of my favorite movies of all time is Everything
Everywhere All at Once.
Oh, I haven't seen it.
Yo, whoa.
Oh, no.
I, okay, I like lost my grip strength for a moment.
Okay, I need to show it to you.
You can show them.
This will be my other checky I decorate.
I'm a domic.
Sorry, Pliskin.
I'll just use it for today.
I may don't make
It's absolutely perfect Thank you, Vicky How long are you
from?
Glad it looked out well I will happily decorate this to go
with us a lot afterwards I'm going for this one, guys No,
mom, I'm 13 I eat unhappy meals now It's too good
Oh no, wait, I know, I know what I want to print out.
Oh, I know what I want to print out.
You haven't done the cat yet, have you?
Huh?
Have you printed the cat yet?
No, no.
Okay, I have a different one.
Don't worry about it.
I'm gonna do this one because if you fail, then it's lighted
out for smoke.
Oh no, there's a cream soda in here.
Cute.
I failed.
Okay, I'm asleep.
should like do it for my friend's stupid cat or if I should
print out niche Chinese baby it's my favorite meme niche
Chinese baby all right are we putting up a poll yeah can we
put up a poll okay okay um all right guys are we doing the
silly cat they don't even know what either looks like Well,
I could, I could just, should I just show them this?
Oh, maybe.
Yeah.
Here.
Should we do this?
This cat?
Or, at least Chinese baby.
The choice is yours, everybody.
The poll has been created.
It is in your hands.
It's in your hands.
Oh, 50-50.
Oh, Baby is slightly taking the lead right now.
Baby taking the lead.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, silly Neko is in the lead.
Oh, oh, my God.
I'll remind everybody of what it looks like.
The tension is palpable.
Silly Neko does seem to be winning.
All right, guys, I'm going to give you another minute.
Go!
Click those buttons!
I think I'm team cat.
Team cat.
I'm also team cat.
It's a beautiful cat.
It's really good.
Really good.
Silly knuckle sweep.
Put your button on the other button.
Do we have any more?
The paper.
Uh.
Go.
There's one under there.
They're like stuck together.
Who?
Ah, that'd be fine.
You guys happen to have the stock taper?
Huh?
Obviously the stock taper.
So stinky.
This white one?
It's so stinky.
Yeah, it really is.
We don't really have edgy decos though.
I know.
But it's okay.
It's kind of like a...
What's the word?
Gap boy.
I did try to buy some...
It didn't arrive, but I tried to buy little little ones.
Little gun charms for snake.
So what?
Gun charms?
Oh no way!
So they did not arrive.
I think I'm done with Shadow Moses Torture Snake.
Maybe?
Shadow Moses Torture Snake with gold!
Maybe I should add a little bit more color though.
Hold on.
Old?
I'm going to also use the smelly one, I'm sorry.
Alright, and the winner silly cat I'm printing it okay thank
you
so simulate the snow look at him getting tortured oh so
kawaii yeah thank you everybody thank you beautiful thank
you thank you ladders are wrong snake everybody Don't make
me pull out, don't make me pull out the graph.
The graph.
I just made that up.
I'm sure there is some sort of like, this snake is this guy
and this snake is this guy.
Come on.
You should make a graph.
I'll make the graph, everybody.
I'll make it.
Guys, the printer is infringing!
No!
It's against the silly cat!
It was Team Chinese baby!
Sabotage.
Wait, did you already print the Chinese baby?
No, but the print is still working now.
Wait, I hope it's okay in general.
Come back there.
Alright everybody, time for...
I made um...
It kind of looks like it's saying Bitcoin.
It's like...
Snake coin.
No, no, it's a snake coin.
Oh,
I hear it.
I hear it being printed.
And then the frogs.
Frog will be utilized.
Nice.
Here you go, please.
Thank you for the poll, which ends at 69, oh sorry, 68?
67% for silly, oh no, it was 69 in the end, okay, nice,
nice.
Wait, 68 is Schrödinger's funny number?
Yeah.
68, sorry, 68 plus or minus 1 is Schrödinger...
It's so, so true!
Funny... or, yeah, Schrödinger's funny number.
Alright guys, time to...
Time to do this one.
Oh yeah!
I'm excited.
Is this one good again?
Was this one good?
Yeah, it's good, it's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one.
I kind of want to use baby for this one.
It's giving baby.
Oh, baby here.
Thank you!
Yeah.
I think I'm gonna be a baby.
Oh, sorry.
No, no, you're fine.
Should've bought more baby, apparently.
That's a pink baby.
But I muster.
Don't do it.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
Two coasts.
Love dies on the block chain.
Oh, second baby.
Well, yeah.
it was printed beautiful no but those like those instant
print is so good yeah isn't that how are like checking this
for the patreon oh I don't know how do they just hide those
running for like hours and hours oh shoot oh no
okay I guess it's It's just there.
It's just gonna have to be there.
That's where it lives now.
I've written baby girl on this one.
I like how you're decorating the place.
I'm gonna make some really dumb bitch energy.
For freedom.
Make use of the pens too guys.
Yes.
Love it.
I've always do this again actually.
I'm enjoying this activity.
I know this is pretty loud.
Yeah.
I want to make more shadow checkies and take them around
everywhere.
Yeah.
It's so cute.
And yeah, if you guys want to do a similar thing with the
checkies from the fan club.
Yeah, you can see how this is our first time making these,
you guys.
We can do it.
Yeah.
Some of you guys have been doing this and like a few of you
have been posting them to Twitter and they are so pretty.
You guys are pros.
You're pros of it?
I don't know how to make this scream the darkness in my
heart more.
It's really good.
Maybe a Labooboo.
Yes, yes.
As anything, yeah.
Yeah, I also might take this other pink Labooboo as anyone
object.
Thank you.
It's yours.
Or a shadow.
It's giving baby girl energy.
Some pink butterflies as well.
Yeah.
this kathy borrow sticker sheet has some darkness in my soul
energy it has this menacing llama oh yeah don't make it the
menacing llama yeah oh menacing la wait why are they
menacing i mean llamas spit at you it's pretty that's why
aren't you menacing that's true oops i bit my heart out for
now okay i might be dumb it
Whatever works, works.
I'm tempted to try Meruku.
Is that- What's in La Pupu?
Excuse me!
How can you tell me that that is La Pupu?
Look at this.
It's beautiful.
Baby, where's the bad smelling one?
Sugar.
Thank you!
You're my A candy girl Girl And you've got me love
I put these like rhino white bits on it but I don't know why
I did that Wait the butterflies are so good Thank you Yeah I
feel like they're definitely giving dub big energy
Hmm, what else do I want that's super color?
Actually, in the game he makes a butterfly, so...
Perfect!
It's perfect!
Oh, I do love the jewels.
They look so cute.
Yeah!
Oh, it looks so good!
Baby girl!
I'm not trying to copy you.
No, no, please.
We're doing similar colors.
I mean, I feel like it's the same energy, you know, Dumbic
and...
Yeah, yeah.
Mom, I'm 13.
I eat on Happy Meals now.
This is my Edglor daughter.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Oh my god, it's too good.
Thank you.
I think the Labubu really does.
Yeah, it does.
It's like that splash of color that just like enhances it.
And it's possibly the most cursed thing that we have in
terms of deco.
So, perfect.
Yeah.
If only those charms would have arrived.
get out of the curse things on the way unfortunately yeah i
would have decorated cookies with guns can i have the pink
uh yes thank you very much yes they're so pretty never mind
if i take this like massive pink shell i had a vision for do
we do other top loaders what are top loaders oh it's this
the plastic thing that you put yes yes Yeah, because I do
want to do rom-coms, but I need to do a scalpel.
You guys will relate to this.
I just bought them as Magic the Gathering card sleeves, so I
don't know what its offloader is.
Here you go.
Thank you.
I feel like the smiley face is throwing off my dumb bitch.
Dumb bitch.
I don't know.
What do you guys think?
What's throwing it off?
This one.
I think it's got good energy.
So yeah, you could I mean you could replace it with another
reboot in the boo boo if you want That's also giving dumb
bick as well
Poplars are a type of washing machine Are they?
Are they?
No, oh, wait, I think I have a top with no, I don't I'm a
liar.
Oh, I guess that's the kind of washing machine that you put
the clothes in through the top Instead of good stuff.
Oh, yeah, that's what I have.
No, they're more popular in Japan or cheaper than All right,
here we go Oh, baby girl.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
So good.
Glad you like it, guys.
Yes, love.
Oh, my God.
It's giving, like, Shadimi.
I know.
I was kind of tempted to do a Shadimi one as well.
Oh, that's looking so good.
Have you got some paper?
Oh, yeah, good.
good oh my nonsense noise I will just have to like I'll just
oh yeah I'll just remove the pieces on the you can do that
or I could I could take the colors of this one that's what I
did with one of these I just put the colored pieces on there
hang on just smudge it oh oh no no no no actually maybe this
won't work oh my god oh is it that oh oh Oh, I sounded like
one of those tubes.
I don't know how I meant that sound.
Okay, I'm sorry, smiley face.
Does anyone want to use him?
I feel bad.
I'll wipe him off.
It's okay, I took the paper out of the Kazi one.
Oh, you sure?
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you for trying though.
I know this is really gonna work to be honest.
Looks like a piece of interpretive, what's it?
Like a abstract art.
You can sell that.
Yeah.
yeah it'll go for thousands and thousands i'm gonna call it
mustard mustard in the dark mustard in the dark whoa deep
deep deep for my 13 years it'll be like my tumbler profile
picture or something
this reflects my soul what are you gonna do for ranka yeah
lots of flowers oh yeah this one she's of my she's so pretty
she's not like oh she's got some blues and pinks and just
want to sell mermaid and baby and fairies together wow i
don't know are you guys all done with you yeah i think so
yeah i think i'll leave this i definitely recommend emerald
for ranka it's very nice the emerald one thank you it is
yeah matches like what she's wearing better than oh
definitely better kiwi don't do that you know what i'm gonna
do with kiwi you know what i'm gonna wait this is this is
kiwi isn't it okay phoebe watch out that's how i feel about
kiwi she just she just jumped it across the room all right i
think i'm done with this guy uh no so good i like this
little frog Dumbik.
Dumbik.
Yay!
I love it.
Do you like kiwis, the fruit?
Yeah, I do.
No, just the, just that color is just...
Here, Phoebe, I'll give these all to you.
Thank you.
I'm gonna...
Everything is yours.
I'm gonna slime mine everywhere.
Can I get the yellow?
I'm gonna actually use...
Oh!
She's so brave.
That's so brave of you.
Oh, for the cat.
I got Veronica.
Are you sure you want to use the yellow?
I'm about to say.
Ewa!
I immediately realized.
The shape is not even...
You're right.
Don't do it.
I was in the wrong here.
I'm sorry, I keep pushing things out.
No, no, go for it.
They're all for you, Phoebe.
Oh boy.
Phoebe, you gotta use all of these on the last one.
No, you don't.
Oh boy.
Else, we're gonna...
That's it.
If we explode.
They're gonna explode.
Oh, no.
Imagine, you wake up in like a chamber, like a cell, and
you're chained to a chair, and then you have deco-deco-den
stuff in front of you, and they're like, me must use all of
this, and decorate stuff, or else there's a timer, there's a
bomb that's rigged to go on.
Oh my gosh.
I know, it's like so hot.
Yeah, it's like so hot.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna add some more to also watch, because I feel like I
didn't, like, Jason will have scrapped over.
That's how I feel about my causing win.
I was like, yeah, I was like, been more bold.
Yeah, I was like, I don't know what I'm doing yet.
I just want to throw Johnny in the bin.
I'm sorry, Johnny.
No, Johnny's is beautiful!
Mustard pour.
Something was off about the spacing for this.
Whatever, I'll just put pink at the end.
What is the inspiration here?
Oh no, oh no, oh my god, oh my god, sorry.
Inspiration here?
Yeah.
Nice.
Wow, I'm inspired.
Alright, if I move these up, I should be able to see the
completed completed works.
Wow, it looks so good!
Yippee!
Baby, where are you gonna use any of these?
These blues...
Um...
Maybe if we're wrong.
Okay.
I'll use the puddles then.
I might draw some blush on.
I should draw a blush on this.
Yeah!
Go for it!
Here's the pink.
I should have done a scene where he learns that he has a
portrait fetish and then he...
And then it could be a pair together!
Yeah!
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, so nice.
Yeah.
Wait, is this the one you use for Shadow?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
Can I take this last little booboo?
Absolutely.
Oh, that was so much fun.
Yeah!
Yeah, so cool.
I was scared to do this because I was like, oh, it looks so
complicated.
Yeah, it's come out so good though.
Yeah.
Oh, that's gonna be ground.
I don't know.
Let's get to it after that.
Yeah!
Cute!
I kind of wanted to make this cat one look more cunt-y, but
I...
I mean...
See, I think I got a Phoebe's mouth and a jump scare.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Are we allowed to say that on Dead Dead Sea Channel?
It's different than saying it without the Y at the end.
Is it?
It is!
Yes.
It is different.
This one is great.
Okay, good.
I'm glad I left the smiley because it goes perfect.
Oh, it's perfect!
I'm glad I just, I'm so glad.
Thanks for saving it.
Mmm.
I'm like trying to think of what to mean.
This guy is very good.
What is that?
I don't know.
It's a little dude.
It's like a little confused bird.
It's funny.
This is from Capybara, Sean.
It's like a brand in this cute leg.
Capybara, plushies and stuff.
Guys, which one do you like so far?
Which one's your favorite out of mine and which one's your
favorite out of things?
Let us know.
Show him.
No, he could be hidden.
Well.
You must show him.
But, but.
He may be the favorite.
Yeah.
I don't think he's anyone's favorite.
I don't think that's the case.
I love him.
Where is John?
Stop it!
Big fan of Don't Bit and Shadow.
Not even Johnny.
Like they're using his government.
I love Johnny.
Bring out Johnny.
No!
Silly Neko.
I agree.
The silly Neko is pretty good.
I love that one.
Well guys.
That's a lot of shadow.
Yeah.
If you want a way to decorate your checkies.
If you want a way to fun decorate your checkies.
Yeah, apparently.
so you can get ones that are better checky size but i just
use magic the gathering uh come on the deck honestly i like
the bigger size though because it has we have more room to
decorate yeah like this one is nice but it blocks the checky
so much so yeah this one these are great oh i'm glad yeah
well there we go fun fun tip for you guys if you want to do
uh deco deco whip as well yeah big ryan here i'll pull out
the ones i worked on too yeah Yeah!
Ronkel may be doing like three times, but...
Oh, I know Russian.
Yeah.
You want to do it.
I could print out, I'll send another one if you want.
Yeah.
I don't know how many stickers we have.
What about Cookie Mew?
And you're about to give some questions.
Oh, yes, look, I have to use them for the Ronkel Mew.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, I have to.
I brought out the butterflies.
That'd be so cute.
Yeah, the butterflies for sure.
For the hotline.
I had a, this one is the one I was most excited about.
Yeah.
Oh, okay, good.
Take your time, Mom.
I love the way you're doing this.
It's so nice.
Yeah, I was not bold and brash enough with the Kaze one, but
it's okay.
I'm proud of you.
You can put your Kaze one here, maybe.
I think you can see it better.
Yay!
I used up so much of this stuff.
Like, we used up so many of the stickers.
Yay!
I'm glad I bought enough.
I wasn't sure.
I think it was just right, didn't we?
Yay!
I was being conservative with the fluffy ones because
they're so cute.
I was like, oh, they're so cute.
They're so cute.
Oh, they're cute.
Oh, come on.
Oh my gosh, wait, which is your guys' favorite of your own
ones?
For me, it's got to be Baby Girl.
I printed last minute, to be honest.
Baby Girl's so good.
It's so good, yeah.
Oh, it's so good.
Love it.
I think I like the torture stick.
I think I think tortoise snake is the one with the with the
rainbow the flowers, you know, yeah, I agree It's really
giving.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, it's amazing.
I mean like objectively.
I like I like this so pretty Like I would say like like Deco
whip skill wise like I think this is like the one that you
sell in the shop Right, right.
I'm very happy with like the way the flowers with the deco
whip.
Yeah The leaves, I'm like, I don't know if I can pull off
the leaves, but I can pull off the leaves.
They're like, yippee!
Objectively, however, however, silly cat, silly cat.
Silly cat is just like an icon for the people.
So beautiful.
Oh, well, well done, guys.
I think we did a good job, actually.
Yeah, I think we did too.
This went better than I thought it would.
I'll be honest.
yeah I thought it was gonna be like you know uh expectation
reality type but I feel like we've all got ones that are
like you know they could be in those demo web shops you know
yeah when we open our Etsy shop you go yeah let's go then
that's you got Etsy shop yeah you'll do your all you can the
patreon and get a checky and then we'll decorate it for you
but you have to buy it yeah as you can see it takes lots of
time takes the full length of a stream someone said dead
sensei dead sensei but that's too good
wow thank you guys thank you any any announcements from you
guys anything you want to announce at the end of the stream
any streams coming up or anything stuff you want to about no
okay thank you thank you for the pink all right oh each demo
touch is out on streaming now oh you guys can go stream each
demo touch yeah happy that you guys enjoyed our oh she
uplink yes yes thank you thank you such a dream come true
wasn't it yeah yeah so nice to see you guys And we love
meeting you during meet and greets too.
Yeah.
Always those nice and warm.
It was so much fun.
It was a banger.
Thanks for streaming.
Thank you guys for coming along to our checky madness.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
Yuppie.
All right.
What's our bye-bye again?
Oh, yes, you dance.
You dance.
Then see you later.
See you
later.
Then see you later.
Bye bye.